que tu te rappelles des pas de cette
samba et
j'ai pu danser la maxime de metz en fête
est ce que tu veux tu veut nous la faire
mettre tout ce que tu fous là guy
déroule à guider série le grand georges
mais qui donne à parthenay je serai je
serai là t'inquiète pas je serai là en
back up alors le partenaire alors je
vous dis en moi normalement je vais te
dire moi je vais te dire élèves
je vais te dire je franchement je vais
te dire j'aurais bien dense avec toi
malheureusement compte at on atteint un
certain niveau de danse on n'a pas loin
de penser en dehors de la piste de danse
comme sûr j'ai pas le droit de me batte
en dehors du tatami voilà non mais donc
shy'm je vais le porter c'est à dire la
moitié quoi je vais te coach et je vais
qu'il ya un problème
bam je m'appelle ok je vais porter tes
pas une opa on y va mettez la shdm et et
le style
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors
[Musique]
alors que je vous le dis à la base
j'étais pas venu
[Applaudissements]